مشاهدينا التصعيد الاسرائيلي سيطر على
المشهد في غزه اليوم ايضا وككل يوم حيث
افاد مراسل الجزيره ان 15 فلسطينيا
استشهدوا واصيب اخرون في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف شقه سكنيه في حي تل السلطان برفح
جنوبي قطاع
غزه
[موسيقى]
بس
كريط اطلع نزلها مين
الامانات يلا بسرعه نزل نزل
ج من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي ينضم الينا مؤمن اذا
الحصيله ترتفع كانوا ثمانيه شهداء الان
الحصيله ارتفعت الى
15 شهيدا في هذا القصف الذي استهدف منزلا
في حي تل السلطان في
رفح
نعم حسن الحصيله قبل قليل ارتفعت الى 15
شهيدا وبحسب الاسماء الشهداء التي وصلتنا
قبل قليل فان جل الشهداء هم من الاطفال
والنساء نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي استهدف شقه
سكنيه داخل منزل عائله نوفل في حي تل
السلطان غرب مدينه رفح بالاضافه الى عشرات
الاصابات التي وصلت الى المستشفى الكويتي
في في المدينه وبحسب المصادر الطبيه داخل
المستشفى فان عدد من الجرحى اصاباتهم
بالغت الخطوره نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي
لهذه الشقه السكنيه بعدد من الصواريخ في
ساعات الليل المتاخره ايضا هنا في مدينه
خان يونس وردتنا مناشدات من عائله الاسطل
لاتش جثامين العشرات من الشهداء في منطقه
السطر الغرب وبحسب شاهد عيام من اقارب هذه
العائله وصل الى تلك المنطقه فان الحديث
عن اكثر من 50 شهيدا من افراد هذه العائله
دمرت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
منازلهم بعدد من الصواريخ ونتيجه الاحزمه
الناريه التي استهدفت تلك المنطقه خلال
الايام الماضيه من بين الشهداء عرف
الصحفيه هبه العبادله وطفلتها بالاضافه
الى والدتها وايضا هناك مناشدات بضروره
التدخل والتنسيق من خلال الصليب الاحمر
لانتشال جثامين الشهداء عدد من الشهداء
جثثهم متحلله بحسب افادات شاهد العيم في
الشارع القريب من المنازل التي تعرضت
للتدمير على رؤوس ساكنيها بالاضافه الى
وجود جثامين الشهداء من الاطفال والنساء
تحت ركام هذه المنازل التي يبدو ان
المنطقه تعرضت لحزام ناري من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه خلال الايام الماضيه
ايضا نسمع دوي اطلاقات ناريه بين فتره
واخرى هنا في مدينه خان يونس ويبدو انها
ناجمه عن استمرار الاشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
عدد من المحاور وتحديدا في المحور الجنوبي
الشرقي في منطقه قيزان النجار ايضا
يتحدثون عن وجود عدد من الشهداء في تلك
المنطقه لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف الوصول
اليها نتيجه الاستهداف الاسرائيلي المتعمد
ومنع سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني
من الوصول اليها الى جانب عدد من العائلات
لازالت محاصره داخل تلك المنازل وسط قصف
مدفعي كثيف في تلك المنطقه التي تشهد
اشتباكات مسلحه بالاضافه الى المحور
الشرقي ببلدات خزاعه وبن سهيلا ومعا وايضا
منطقه عبسان والى جانب منطقه المحطه
والكتيبه في وسط القطاع القصف المدفعي
الاسرا ي لا يتوقف على مخيمي البريج
والمغازي والزوايده بالاضافه الى ان
البوارج الحربيه الاسرائيليه تفتح نيران
اسلحتها بين الفينه والاخرى على ساحل
مدينه دير البلح وايضا المنطقه الغربيه من
مخيم النصيرات الذي شهد هو الاخر سلسله من
الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه استهدفت عددا
من المنازل وايضا القذائف المدفعيه التي
تطال منازل المواطنين داخل المخيم ايضا
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى يعاني نقصا حادا في
الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه الى جانب
النقص الكبير في عدد الكوادر الطبيه نتيجه
توافد المئات من الجرحى يوميا الى
المستشفى وايضا عدم قدره القدره
الاستيعابيه لمستشفى على استيعاب هذه
الاعداد الكبيره من الاصابات اسرائيل تدفع
بالناس الى مدينه رفح وهي المدينه
الحدوديه التي لا تتوف فيها مقومات اساسيه
لاكثر من مليون ونصف المليون نازح داخل
المدينه وتقصفه بطائرات الحربيه حيث ان
جميع المنازل والشقق السكنيه التي يلجا
اليها النازحون او سواء داخل المدارس
تستهدف من قبل الطائرات الحربيه بالصواريخ
في ساعات الليل المتاخر ويبدو ان جيش
الاحتلال يهدف الى ايقاع اكبر قدر من
الخسائر البشريه وتحديدا في صفوف الاطفال
والنساء الامنين داخل منازلهم في ساعات
الليل وفي الاجواء البارده مع المنخفض
الجوي الذي بدا يدخل على قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات الماضيه مؤمن الشرافي من خانيونس
شكرا جزيلا
لك